about above a cross after against among
a lot I'm trying to make a little
replica and then going through the
functions of them it helps me to
remember things by just kind of drying
stuff out and labeling the parts that I
don't remember off the top of my head I
am tracing the picture of the brain it's
kind of like I'm making a test for
myself pinto beans our lima beans and
kidney beans similar carrots peas kidney
beans
I feel like this is going very poorly
a lot of times when I'm in a group there
will be somebody who like tries to
spearhead the whole thing and it just
kind of makes everybody else feel left
out let's have everybody read a section
I like to take over things this tea
could be probably I didn't do that one
Impressionism Expressionism I don't
particularly like group study but I'm
glad we did for this one just because
art is not my forte
flashcards are great I use them most of
the time I was able to draw pictures to
kind of help me remember right now I'm
counting all the stars I can remember
like how many points that I'm gonna have
to connect trying to draw some sort of
visual cue around them I just know that
it's like this or like this well based
on the test I would say that the most
successful was the flashcards found out
that flashcards the way that I worked it
ended up being probably more beneficial
than other things that I did I found
that I was actually a lot better at
flashcards than I thought I was as far
as using them there memorize stuff if
you're not doing so well in school maybe
you're haven't found the exact way to
educate yourself yet know who you are
and how you learn and embrace it as
something that's unique to you do what
you feel is comfortable and if it takes
you a little bit longer that's okay